in an exclusive interview you will see
only on cbs this morning we always like
when that happens we spoke with apple
ceo tim cook
about the aftermath of the assault on
the capitol apple has removed the social
media app parlor which is popular with
the far right from its app store
tim cook says the platform violated
apple's terms of service
by not adequately monitoring posts that
incite violence
we talked about the attack and asked him
what he thinks needs to happen next
i think it's key that people be held
accountable for it this is not something
that should skate
this is something that we've got to be
very serious about and understand
and and then we need to move forward
do you think the president president
trump should be held accountable for it
when you said people should be held
accountable
there's a whole discussion about that
even as we sit here today
i think no one is above the law i mean
that's a great thing about our country
and we're a rule of law country yeah i
think everyone that had a part in it
needs to be held accountable
we're all told this is a little kid
there are consequences to your actions
but i don't know how we just let this go
i would agree
i don't think we should let it go i
think holding people accountable is
important
and you can see more of our exclusive
interview with tim cook tomorrow on cbs
this morning he's
listen we should say he didn't sit and
say you know i want to talk to cbs about
this this was an interview that was
scheduled because they have a big
announcement that they want to
announce tomorrow it is not a new
product we should say it is not a new
product to get everybody excited yeah
it's something i think bigger and better
than that so we did an interview and we
did it at the apple store here and he's
at his headquarters
um and he you know agreed to answer
other questions but that wasn't the
purpose of the interview it's very
exciting what they're
what what we're going to tell you about
tomorrow is very exciting news but it's
always good to hear from him
he's somebody who's a good human being
he's a very strong business leader
who deeply cares about this country and
deeply cares about what is happening in
it
and wants to do wants to do do good yeah
and and has been a major player on
privacy prior to this
and the conversation around parlor and
what should be allowed and what
shouldn't be allowed will continue for
sure exactly right
at the forefront of it